you know that you're an amazing singer
we know that your husband mike is an
amazing hockey player maybe not the best
singer is he the one that you go to for
honest opinions when it comes to your
new music no
no why
he will definitely be brutally honest
but he's not my fan you know what i mean
he's my husband and there's stuff that
like i don't think he heard until
i was done
[Music]
obviously i
value his opinion and his thoughts and
his feelings in this context not so much
and i don't mean that in a disrespectful
way yeah
he's not gonna come to me for like man i
had a terrible game like what do i need
to do in the next game you know what i
mean so and i'd be like i don't know
like you look good out on the ice like
look fine to me
[Music]
we listen to very different kinds of
music
just in our musical tastes so i don't
know if he would be a carrie underwood
fan if he was not married to oh
no what does he listen to
it's more what i listen to
i love like super hard rock music yeah i
love you know country music i love the
ladies of country music
i'll just leave at that